queen elizabeth ii was britain's longest
reigning monarch a popular and
stabilizing force who ruled for over 70
years
during her reign she became a cultural
and political icon the subject of
hollywood films
and tv shows the crown must win
as well as a host to an array of global
leaders
but others in the royal family are not
as popular including her successor king
charles iii in a recent poll 32 of the
british public said he wouldn't make a
good king
in recent years some members have also
been embroiled in scandals and royal
rifts have spilled into the public eye
so as the country mourns the queen the
transition to a pneumonic is a delicate
one as charles and the rest of the
family have to step up to fill the void
she leaves and make their own mark
here's how it will work
first consider that the queen is deeply
embedded in almost every aspect of
britain's everyday life
[Applause]
the british national anthem has been
sung in honour of the queen
her image is emblazoned on cash and
coins and on postage
and every uk passport is issued in the
queen's name
so as king charles ascends to the throne
all of these items will need to be
updated a process that is expected to
take years and could cost billions
culturally it will be a big change for
the uk where most people were born under
the queen's reign
[Music]
and while those changes can happen
gradually the royals face the immediate
challenges of preparing for the queen's
funeral and subsequent coronation of
king charles
like his mother and other british
monarchs for the past 900 years king
charles is expected to have his
coronation service at westminster abbey
but even as he continues those
long-standing traditions the monarch is
expected to make some key changes
aides say he wants to slim down and
lower the cost of the monarchy as an
institution while remaining very active
in britain's national life
part of that will be determined by where
charles will live or spend most of his
time the british royal family has many
estates including balmoral in scotland
where the queen died and sandringham
where the family traditionally spends
christmas
charles is widely expected to move into
buckingham palace the administrative
headquarters of the monarchy whereas in
recent years the queen spent much of her
time at windsor castle outside of london
one of the hardest tasks for charles
will be to establish his moral authority
he takes over in the wake of family
rifts from prince harry leaving his
royal duties to prince andrew's
friendship with convicted sex offender
jeffrey epstein
in the past the king's own personal life
has been the subject of interest for the
nation's tabloids particularly in the
1990s following his separation from lady
diana and remarriage to camilla
parker-bowles who will now become queen
consort
his son and heir to the throne william
is more popular than his father
overall the public perception of the
monarchy has changed in 2012 more than
70 percent of british respondents in a
survey said they supported the royals
ten years later that number has dropped
by 11 points and one in five people
questioned if the uk should move to have
an elected head of state like a
president
that's a choice many countries that used
to be part of the commonwealth have
already made barbados was the latest
country to remove the queen as head of
state in 2021
during a visit to the caribbean island
charles didn't shy away from addressing
the family's colonial history from the
darkest days
of our past
and the appalling atrocity of slavery
which forever stains our history
one key difference between charles and
his mother while the queen steered clear
of political debates charles has often
called for change in action on issues
such as climate change
as all the
horrors of even a two-degree warmer
world bite
and bite they will
royal aids says king charles will step
back from campaigning and overall they
expect his popularity to rise as people
embrace him as a monarch as he becomes
king at 73 charles iii has had decades
to prepare and study for this role
unlike his mother who was in her 20s
when she became queen
still he faces a delicate task as he
shapes the future of the british
monarchy